kernig Schlueter is a small village in
lower saxony with an old town full of
barak and medieval half-timbered houses
the backdrop could hardly look more
German into this picturesque setting
enter 30 refugees from Somalia and Sudan
they arrived in Germany a few months ago
and applied for asylum the scene is
being repeated in many other towns as
more and more refugees come to Germany
by the end of 2013 the numbers could top
100,000 the highest in more than a
decade the welcome has been mixed of
course we've noticed a lot more
dark-skinned people around here but then
they have to go somewhere let me say
about it I'd send them all home
disastrous what do they want here they
didn't flee just because they enjoy
fleeing they're in a bad situation
they're friendly and nice we've already
celebrated a festival together carnac's
mutters mayor admits taking in the
refugees has posed some major challenges
for his town of 15,000 people but the
town is obligated to help both legally
and morally if we consider the world's
situation today I think Germany has an
obligation to take in refugees of course
for a town the size of critics Goethe it
isn't that easy because we have to see
we're living space is available and
where we can accommodate these people
well come on use a pension or doubling
carnac's looter has no shelters or
dormitories as of yet the refugees are
staying in tenement blocks in a
residential area
now after a somewhat bumpy start they're
getting along well with their German
neighbors
they've even learned to sort their trash
a German specialty I don't have any
problems with these people they're
decent as far as I'm concerned if
they're ever loud it's only briefly it
doesn't bother us the federal government
pays the rent and provides 320 euros a
month allowance for each asylum seeker
the refugees say that by far they prefer
Germany to their home countries I hope
I'll be able to stay here there's more
in my home country Somalia but I feel
safe here
Germany has become my second home
everyone is very helpful and they've
received us very well the mayor would
like to get a first hand look at the
refugees living situation there contact
people and helpers are mostly volunteers
from an aid organization the volunteers
criticize the City Council for leaving
the refugees to fend for themselves I'm
an intelligent concept for dealing with
these refugees would be nice a concept
that informs the helpers and the
volunteers about the mentality of these
people about where they come from how
they think what their religion is and do
we have anyone here from their religion
who can welcome them we're hugely
dependent on the volunteers
contributions we wouldn't be able to
handle it on our own the way it is
obviously the volunteers are very
important but they're not the only ones
I think the government could do a bit
more the mayor says the criticism is
justified but the town's budget simply
doesn't have room for him to do more
it's what we really need is someone in a
permanent position to take charge I
think that's a job the state and federal
governments should see about and that's
how I see this German class wouldn't
even be possible without the voluntary
commitment of two retired grade school
teachers a commitment that's beginning
to pay off is mouthing I didn't touch
them the refugees say that next to the
language their biggest problem is the
tedium bicycles that some of the local
people donated are some help
but the asylum seekers can't range very
far by law they are only allowed to
leave the country in exceptional
circumstances it's still necessary to
keep tabs on everyone and to know where
they are at any given moment because
decisions sometimes have to be made at
relatively short notice or there might
be a hearing in the procedure so I think
the residential obligation is the right
thing it takes an average of eight
months for a decision to be made on an
application only a small fraction of the
applicants will be granted asylum in
Germany about 1% last year but around a
third of the refugees can stay
temporarily connect Schlueter will be
receiving even more refugees soon the
mayor is having living containers set up
on city property they'll provide room
for up to 50 asylum seekers at a cost to
the community of about 50 thousand euros
but if we can set up containers as we
need them and take them down when we
don't have as many asylum seekers that's
a flexibility that we definitely need
these containers have to be ready to
move into by October if the new refugees
show up earlier the town will have a
housing shortage